[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us
epic was founded on building great games
and sharing all of our technology openly
with the community we succeed when you
succeed and we want all developers to
have the advantages we have ourselves
when building games like fortnite unreal
engine 5 is the latest chapter
we released the early access preview
back in may and the community has built
some amazing things in it let's take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
today we're launching unreal engine 5.0
to all developers it's been battle
tested in fortnite chapter 3 launched
last december so download it today and
get started
what's most exciting now is that
real-time 3d is bringing industries
together with honorable engine 5 as
their common medium
among game developers 48 of announced
next generation console titles are
powered by unreal automotive designers
fashion designers and architects are
doing everything from design
visualization to brand activations and
entertainment crossovers film and
television producers are using unreal
for virtual production on set and for
final pixels on the movie screen then
they're bringing their content to games
and live events on a mass scale
we're seeing the emergence of a new
medium connecting people around the
world live and shared experiences
whoever you build today is a stepping
stone to bigger things in the future so
come join us on the journey and we'll
build this future together
next up i'd like to introduce kim le
berry cto of epic games
hello everybody i can't believe it's
been eight years since we shipped unreal
engine four
and seven years since we made it free
for everybody's use
since then we've seen huge growth in
engine usage spanning games as well as
many other industries
this incredible journey has afforded us
the opportunity to work with some of the
best creators from all over the planet
it's the work which has driven us to
keep pushing the envelope to the point
where we are today which is the release
of unreal engine 5. one of the founding
principles of the company is that we
bring the lessons we learn from our own
game development back into unreal the
scale and success of fortnite took that
model to a whole new level putting all
that work back into the engine has made
unreal engine way better across all
platforms
i joined epic because i've always
believed that real-time technology has
the power to revolutionize the creative
process across all industries
being able to make instantaneous
decisions within a near photoreal
interactive environment is utterly
transformative
it empowers you to make big changes to a
scene and see them immediately in
context
this is a better quicker and much more
efficient way of creating content it's
been fantastic to see our customers
using the engine in so many different
ways from indie creative projects all
the way up to aaa games and even movies
but for us to really be sure that unreal
engine 5 has achieved the goals we set
for it to really change the way
interactive and linear media is made
we needed to push the engine to a new
extreme
and that's how the matrix awakens demo
came about
how do we know what is real
i was fortunate enough to have worked in
the first three matrix movies at a time
when visual effects was revolutionizing
the movie business
having the opportunity to work on
another matrix project and push
technology yet again was really special
it was a privilege for us to bring the
matrix universe to a whole new
generation of viewers and players we
wanted to show that high-end visuals at
a massive scale were possible in a
living breathing and believable open
world and we wanted to show that a
player could be immersed in an exciting
cinematic scene that would normally only
be possible in a blockbuster film
what's been fantastic is seeing how a
fully interactive set can change the
process of filmmaking
in what can be described as life
imitating art we actually filmed the
cinematic sections of the demo inside
the matrix city we had built
where our artists would drive cars
set up stunts and place pyrotechnics all
inside a fully simulated world
and because this is a simulation that
can be recorded by unreal we can then
place optimal cameras in the scene after
the fact to give maximum cinematic
impact
unreal engine 5 isn't just about making
existing ways of doing things faster
it's about finding whole new approaches
to transform the way content is made and
experienced
micro polygon geometry allows for
billions of triangles on the screen at
any moment and luma's real-time global
illumination enables highly realistic
lighting they combine together to
generate real-time content at a level
that would have seemed like magic only a
few years ago
for the building of the matrix megacity
we didn't have a huge environment team
so we had to build it in a really smart
and efficient way we wanted to create a
large-scale city with fidelity and
complexity beyond what is typical in an
open world game and for this we deployed
procedural content creation techniques
including partnering with our friends at
side effects to use houdini and houdini
engine
developer efficiency is a recurring
theme that goes beyond unreal engine and
into our other products
meta human creator and quicksort maker
scans show how we're enabling creators
to make very high quality content more
quickly than ever before pulling
together the city for the matrix awakens
and bringing it to life would have been
impossible without these tools
unreal engine is revolutionizing how
creators tell stories and how people
experience them
enabling developers to leverage one set
of assets for whatever type of content
they can dream up from games to linear
animation and even to live action shows
and movies
one of the most important aspects of
creating the matrix awakens demo was our
commitment to release the city as a
sample content
we want to show in a step-by-step manner
how we created this world together and
to provide a starting point for others
to make their own worlds tell stories
even build new games on top of this
incredible digital city
unreal engine 5 is the foundation of
next-gen content creation so what are
you waiting for go make something
amazing
[Applause]
starting today it's never been easier to
bring your creative vision to life
we built ue5 by looking at each
individual aspect and asking ourselves
what technical hurdles can we remove to
help developers put creativity first we
redesigned the unreal editor ui making
it easier to use with a streamlined
modern look keeping you inside the 3d
world that you're building and we built
tools for animation and modeling
directly into the editor enabling
developers to fine-tune and iterate on
content in context without round trips
to external packages
lumen frees developers to create dynamic
worlds with high quality global
illumination
nanite relieves developers from worrying
about draw call polygon and memory
budgets from a geometry perspective
and our new open world tools allow
developers to collaborate in a single
massive level
and to get you building even faster
alongside ue5 we're shipping lyra a new
starter game it's a complete end-to-end
networked multiplayer game project that
is an excellent foundation to build a
game upon without having to start from a
blank slate
it's built for modular components
utilizes epic online services for
matchmaking and is designed to run on pc
console and mobile with lyra you can
jump in customize it add new content and
begin play testing from day one
to see how easy it is to build on top of
lyra let's jump in the editor with zach
parrish
okay so here we are inside of the unreal
editor and this is the lyra project and
this is the expanse level one of three
different levels that ship with the lyra
project and i'm just gonna jump right in
and play the game so i'll click the play
button and boom we're we're playing lyra
inside the editor and i know there's a
bot waiting for me up here and he's
gonna try to get the shotgun and i can't
let that happen because it won't go well
for me come on i can do this
okay well saw that coming it's probably
going to happen a lot throughout this
demo now what we're going to be focusing
on is how we can take this level and
modify it and really start to make lyra
our own but before we do that i want to
call out the lighting this level is lit
primarily with just the sunlight as a
matter of fact if i move the sun around
you can see how lumen just takes that
light and naturally bounces it around
the scene and the light is influenced by
the surface as it hits so if i was to
take the floor for example and just drag
and drop a new material on it like like
red for example you can now see there's
red light bouncing around the scene and
if you really just want to
crank it up to 11 i could drag and drop
like this neon green color that i
imported from the early 90s and you can
see that the sunlight hits that and
floods the whole scene with green light
now i would never leave it that way
because that looks awful
now in addition to bounced light
lumen also allows us to illuminate our
scenes using emissive materials so
here's a ball that has an emissive
material on it and it is casting light
into the scene but it's hard to see with
all this sunlight so let's just take the
sun and tuck it up underneath the level
and now you can see that the ball
actually is casting light and there is
no light actor there this is all
happening by way of the material thanks
to lumen in fact if i take the material
and change its color we can change the
color of the light and if i increase
that emissive value we can actually
flood the scene with more light and and
in the process make a sphere that's
actually painful to look at
now that light is dynamic you can see as
i move the ball around
that lighting is following along
so let's take a look at modifying our
level i'll just tuck the ball up here
into the corner and let's bring the sun
back
now lyra was designed from the ground up
for you to build your own games on and
to help with that we've created a series
of tools to help you out
so this looks like a regular static mesh
of a window that i just duplicated off
the back wall but actually this is a
procedural mesh so if i get it into the
middle of the room
and then right click on it and go to
scripted actor actions i can swap this
out to its generated mesh and now we can
see a selection of handles that i can
move around and you see how that updates
the object so i can move the window
around inside the shape and if i go over
to the details panel i can increase the
wall's width we could increase its
height
we could actually adjust you know what
let's take the opening and we'll change
it to make this into like a bunker that
i can kind of hide behind to give me
some protection from these bots so we'll
make that narrow we'll slide it down a
little bit
maybe i'll increase the width by just a
little and when i'm done i just need to
convert this into a regular static mesh
i'll do that by clicking generate new
static mesh and then right click
and choose swap to static mesh and boom
this is a mesh just like any other that
you'd use to build a level now of course
we're not limited to just duplicating
existing meshes if i wanted to i can
bring in fresh ones from the tools menu
that's included in the lyra install and
you'll find that this is full of a
series of these procedural tools that
are all built using blueprint on top of
the already existing modeling tools in
the unreal editor so i can bring in this
panel and just move this handle around
to quickly drag out a ceiling for our
little bunker and if i'm happy with that
just right click
and swap that over to a static mesh now
i do need a way to get up here which
i'll admit the whole thing was just an
excuse for me to show you this really
cool procedural stairway so if i drag
this in check it out i'm going to rotate
it around and aim it where it needs to
go
and then we're going to move it way far
back and obviously these stairs leave a
little bit to to be desired in terms of
where they're going but if i grab the
handle in the upper corner watch this we
can increase their length
and we can increase their height
and the system just automatically
generates stairs for me so
we'll just connect those right up and
make a couple of quick edits there we go
that looks pretty good and we can also
make them wider so we'll just
slide that out like so i don't know why
it needed a sound effect but for some
reason i feel like it did now we can
also change the number of stairs as well
so i can take the step height and you
can see i can adjust that we can make
these into floating stairs let's make
sure that they are creating some
collision and i i have to mention this
because it just it makes me so
fundamentally happy but if you get right
down on the stairs we can actually turn
on bevel and we can add just a little
bit of bevel to the edge of the stairs
which really helps when the the light
hits them just so
if we're done if we're happy we can just
right click and go back to scripted
actor actions swap that out to a static
mesh and there we go we've built a new
part of the level of course it does have
this really cool prototyping grid
material but let's make it fit the scene
just a little bit better
we'll add some color to it we'll bring
in some red for the top area
and i'll make the stairs blue because
that's what i have handy and there we go
now
it'd be great if i also had some
armaments and we have access to the
entire gameplay library that makes lyra
so here is a weapon spawner and by the
way this is defined entirely in
blueprint so if i wanted to open this up
and change its behavior i could
i wouldn't even have to write a line of
code but all i'm going to do is change
some settings so let's take the weapon
definition and we'll set that over to
rifle and i'll take the color and set it
over to pink so that everybody knows
that this is my rifle and i'm the only
one who gets to use it
and if if i wanted to we could just test
this out so
let's hit play
and i'll quickly run up the steps
and i know that bot is coming i can feel
it
come on
okay
oh they went upstairs all right well
let's take our bunker we'll grab our
rifle now i got cover ah here we go yeah
that's right come on come on
i don't know why i'm adding sound
effects i can't help it
but see there you go just like that i
was able to change the overall flow of
the level from something very open and
frenetic to some place where i have
cover where i can pick up a weapon and
really try to to control the situation
and i did that using procedural tools
that are already included with lyra
now of course we're not limited to that
we have the entire epic games ecosystem
we have the marketplace we have
sketchfab we have quixil bridge there's
even art station and you can bring in
content from those and really make lyra
look like anything you want it to be so
here's a statue that we actually had
from a previous project so i could just
drag this in
and of course this looks great it has a
lot of fantastic detail but it doesn't
quite fit the overall flow of lyra so
let's just fix that i'll just drag a new
material on it surely no art director
would have a problem with that
but the point is that you can just add
whatever content your heart desires and
really start turning your lyra levels
into anything you want them to be
so now you've seen how you can build
your own games and experiences inside of
lyra and this was using just one of
three modes available inside the project
we have elimination which is like a
standard death match we have control
which is like a capture and hold mode
and there's even exploder which is like
a top down party game and all of this is
available to you today
that's great zach thanks
even though this is the first release of
ue5 we've made sure the engine is ready
to ship projects from day one we're
proud of the demos we built to drive
development of unreal engine 5 lumen in
the land of nanite valley of the ancient
for our early access release and the
matrix awakens available to players
around the world on xbox series x and
series s and playstation 5. but to
really put the engine through its paces
last december we shipped chapter 3 of
fortnite on unreal engine 5 across all
platforms pc ps4 and ps5 xbox one series
x and series s nintendo switch and
android
we completed a rigorous process
comparing the performance memory and
stability of fortnite on ue5 with
fortinet on ue4
and we were able to make the transition
smoothly without any major modifications
to fortnite's code or content
and the fortnite team was able to take
advantage of the new editor and
workflows in ue5 having taken the plunge
ourselves you can be confident that ue5
is battle tested and ready for
production
now our goal has always been for all
developers to be able to take advantage
of ue5 whether you're already working in
ue4 or starting anew
we made sure the path to transition from
ue4 to 5 is straightforward and well
documented so you can hit the ground
running with all of the new features
right away
this is just the beginning future
updates will include new features
improvements and optimizations and we're
arming you with an arsenal of libraries
and additional tools with the power of
creation in your hands day one to
preview some of these incredible tools
let's go to our friends at epic
stockholm in sweden
hey everyone teddy here
high quality food reel content is
incredibly expensive and time consuming
to create
our mission is to bring you vast
libraries of high quality assets already
made for you and awesome tools for
creating your own photoreal content and
digital humans more quickly than ever
before so that you can concentrate on
what matters most creating amazing
experiences i founded qixel over a
decade ago with the vision to build mega
scans a massive library of ready-made
food real assets to simplify digital
world creation for developers
all built with state-of-the-art scanning
technology a single such asset contains
millions of triangles and in the past
making use of such high fidelity content
to create billion polygon scenes was
limited to the motion picture industry
and could simply not be done in games
but now with the advent of unreal engine
5 and nanite micro polygon geometry it's
finally possible to use this movie
quality content as is to create
real-time experiences that are
indistinguishable from reality
regardless of which industry you're in
when kwixel joined epic we immediately
made the entire mega scans library free
for use with unreal engine and started
work on integrating it into the engine
itself to enable you to use all these
incredibly high fidelity assets directly
in engine
with the release of unreal engine 5 you
can now access the world's largest
library of the highest quality scans for
free fully and anti-compatible without
ever having to leave the editor with a
simple drag and drop you can instantly
stream in full real nanai content to
build any world imaginable
and if you need even more assets and
can't find what you need in the mega
scans library or unreal engine
marketplace we join forces with both art
station and sketchfab working to make
millions of additional marketplace
assets more accessible to developers
we're solving the problem of content
creation at scale with libraries of free
assets and paid work class assets from
creators featuring the best revenue
share in the industry
sometimes you might not find exactly the
assets you're looking for and would like
to create it yourself but take it from
me scanning custom assets has always
been incredibly hard work that requires
a great deal of training as well as
specialized and expensive hardware
software
for this reason we've been working to
distill our scanning experience and
technology into an easy to use phone app
bringing the gold standard of
photogrammetry straight into your pocket
we're calling this app reality scan it
intelligently guides you through the
scanning process in ar to ensure optimal
quality
processes all data automatically in the
cloud and publishes the final assets
straight to sketchfab for use anywhere
all for free our goal is to make it as
easy as possible for you to create and
share your own custom for real content
whenever you need it for the exact same
reason we also released metahumancreator
a free cloud-based app that empowers
professionals as well as beginners to
create fortrealistic digital humans
complete with hair and clothing in
minutes
this used to be incredibly challenging
and time consuming but now you can
create your own digital humans at the
quality of the best looking games out
there
so by combining this incredible free
creator ecosystem of best in class tools
and movie quality content with the power
of unreal engine 5 creating amazing
photoreal games and experiences has
never been this easy with all these new
free tools you'll be able to start
building an exciting new ways developed
by both you and the community as a whole
and to tell you more about another great
community resource here is shirt
thank you teddy the community of
creators all over the world is something
that is very dear to us at epic
i started my personal journey when i
first discovered unreal engine 23 years
ago when i was just 15 years old
i started creating levels for arnold
tournaments join this community and it
changed my life as we've seen it do for
so many others
we are excited to provide the engine and
our whole ecosystem of tools to everyone
but we're equally thrilled to ensure
that we equip creators with the
knowledge and support you need to
succeed making it as easy as possible to
find and share knowledge across the
community
with the next generation of unreal
engine launching we have been working on
a new community site
dev.epigames.com
community the site brings together a
number of different community channels
and tools to make it easy to find all of
our resources in one place learning
content forums questions and answers and
code snippets
the learning section is a centralized
fully open and accessible library of all
kinds of courses tutorials live streams
and tech talks for you to browse through
and read or watch
and what i really like is that anyone
can write tutorials and contribute to
this library of content through an easy
to use tutorial editor
that lets you freely build up your page
using text image video and code widgets
if for example you discover how to do
amazing procedural animation using
control rig to add secondary motion to
your characters you can share those
learnings with other devs
the unreal engine forums have been fully
integrated in order to give you space to
showcase your cool projects discuss
things with other devs or to find
solutions from others
there is also the snippet repository to
share and store snippets of code such as
c plus and python or text-based assets
such as blueprint materials meta sounds
and so on
for example
in the lyra starter game one of our devs
made a blueprint setup that measures the
running speed of the player and then
uses that to drive reactive music via
metasound
if you have an interesting setup like
that you could simply copy and paste
that from the anvil editor to the
snippets on the site and by doing so
store things you would like to remember
or more importantly share with others so
that they can use your work as a
foundation
and lastly activity is captured and
represented through your profile that
you can personalize to represent who you
are and what you create
if you're looking to up your skills or
if you have questions and you need help
with something or perhaps simply to show
your awesome work or discoveries come
and join us in the unreal engine
community at
death.epicgames.com
community i'm always so inspired by all
the amazing work that is being created
by everyone around the world
we count ourselves fortunate to be able
to give back to our amazing community in
the form of mega grants and fellowship
programs
today we are proud to highlight some of
the astounding work being produced by
the community and here's this example of
all that amazing work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is awesome to see so many inspiring
projects from game developers filmmakers
and creators of animated entertainment
lifting up their voices and vision
through the power of unreal engine
we are thrilled to confirm that all of
the amazing studios you see here are a
part of the unreligion five community
which continues to grow every day
this represents an insanely talented
population of creative technical talent
spanning thousands of people across the
planet who are working on just about any
and every type of project you can think
of and many of these teams are hiring
this year officially marks 20 years of
unreal engine on xbox along with
unprecedented adoption of unreal engine
across microsoft's internal teams who
are building games that the industry
will be talking about for the next 5 10
15 years
and that leads us to a world-class
studio that is very dear to epic the
coalition the team behind the gears
franchise they have been instrumental in
helping the rubber meet the road where
it really counts
it is my pleasure to turn it over to
kate raynor and colin penty
we've been working with unreal engine 5
for over a year now and
we've already seen a lot of the benefits
our relationship with epic has really
impacted positively the gears of war
franchise whether it's collaboration or
calls about various systems or
contributing code we've been creating
numerous prototypes and demos and we're
happy to show you some of the results
today
what you're seeing now is our alpha
point demo it was an early access demo
that we showed at gdc in 2021
there are a few different components and
abbreviated character cinematic
and a early large world technical test
the open world tech test was built to
test a few things it was built to test
the landscape system how does it react
with nanite
how does world partition streaming
function and how do these all come
together and perform on xbox
[Music]
so metahumans came out about halfway
through our character rendering visual
tech test demo and so we immediately
sort of stopped what we were doing for a
bit took a look at metahumans and wanted
to see how it could augment our existing
character that we were building and so
we pulled things like materials from
metahumans and eyeballs and teeth and
bring it all together and just see what
level of fidelity we could hit throwing
all the latest tech and unreal engine 5
at it
this cinematic demo brings the character
quality of the new rendering systems the
environment technologies the new lumen
rendering system
all together to create a real-time
cinematic experience that goes beyond
anything that we've done in the past
i'm personally very proud of them they
were all sort of labors of love for
myself and the art team and engineering
teams and really opened our eyes towards
what the next gen quality visual bar
could be and so it was a huge learning
experience for us and i think it
actually set us up really well when epic
came and asked for help on the matrix
awakens demo the fact that we were able
to ship
this experience on xbox series s with
all the same features including ray
tracing that we had on the xbox series x
at such a high quality level is really
amazing
with the launch of unreal engine 5 what
i'm most excited for is the developer
efficiency that we have for our team we
really are able to deliver a triple a
experience that we've always wanted to
without the compromises
unreal engine 5 i feel like is a huge
game changer and i feel like we haven't
fully even realized how much of a game
changer it's going to be it basically
democratizes game development across the
world and yes there's accelerations for
aaa developers like ourselves but also
is a great
entry point for indie dev studios and so
i think it furthers along on real engine
4's vision of everyone can build a
project and build a game and i think
it's going to change the entire industry
thanks so much kate and collin the work
across microsoft and the coalition make
unreal engine better for everyone
cd projekt red are experts in open world
game design with the witcher 3 and
cyberpunk 2077 combining freedom of
exploration with compelling storytelling
in unparalleled fashion
through a new partnership with epic cd
projekt red is building a brand new
witcher saga with ue5
our cooperation with epic has just
started it was the shift towards
open world support that brought unreal
engine 5 to our attention
so there was one demo that happened last
year that was the medieval environment
demo where
at one point uh there's a notice board
that looks strangely familiar to things
we've done in the past that has even a
sign that says monster slayer wanted and
i'm like hmm are they are they trying to
tell us you know come come over to
unreal engine look how great your games
could look on there is that was that
whole demo made with that nefarious
purpose i don't know but it definitely
definitely caught my eye
this opens a new chapter for us where we
really want to see how our experience in
building open world games it's combined
with all the engineering power of epic
one of the things that is really
important to keep in mind when when
talking about open world games versus
let's say linear games is
the possibilities of the things that can
go wrong or the the the scenarios that
you have to consider are
exponentially higher than linear games
players can go in whatever direction
that they want they can handle content
in in any order that they want
theoretically and to really encapsulate
that means that you need a really stable
environment where you can be able to
make changes with a high level of
confidence that it's not going to break
in 600 other places down the line
unreal engine is like a toolbox which
has a lot of features a lot of solutions
already there that allow teams to just
try new stuff the fact that unreal is
used by a lot of teams already in the
world a lot of perspectives are
projected into the design of the tools
and that helps the tool to be way more
agile so all in all it's a really really
cool technology to like prototype and
make environments really quickly
really beautiful and very realistic
epic and cd projekt red are the two
companies that really want to achieve
something great we won't stop just you
know by
developing some features we won't stop
there yeah we will continue to work
together to achieve something
extraordinary in the end
thank you to the cd projekt red team for
providing this great insight into why
you are placing your bets on ue5
we've touched upon how great
storytellers are turning to unreal and
this applies to many different
disciplines whether you're a game
designer or a cinematographer that
common language that real time parlance
is unreal engine 5.
few people understand this better than
aaron sims
unreal engine 5 allows for a creative to
be able to create anything that they've
dreamed of into reality
after being in the industry for over
three decades i've seen a lot of changes
in the visual effects industry i've seen
a lot of great innovations but there's
been nothing like unreal engine 5. i
think it's still new to the community in
some ways as far as looking at it as a
storytelling tool a lot of people think
of it as a game tool or other things i
think that there's so much capacity for
storytelling
[Music]
so what was exciting working on valley
of the ancient
it was our first look at unreal engine 5
and all the different tools were amazing
but the control rig is one aspect that i
think is really exciting
it's so important to actually have
realistic movement not only the look and
feel and the lighting of the character
but the movement has to be realized in a
way that as the audience you believe
them
and so you have all the tools using
control rig the face rig
and being able to use mocap for me was a
lifesaver and to be able to bring it in
engine and just rework a few things here
and there and i was done
all in unreal
is pretty amazing
the great thing again about unreal it's
a lot of fun to be able to play within
that sandbox
and what's also important is to be able
to have access to assets
[Music]
the marketplace is a great resource
there's a lot of free content
and we as a matter of fact actually
added to that library and it's a
creature from our film called the eye
callum deck
many humans created this ability to have
an artist tell their story with a human
character and believe them
the fact that the shaders and the
textures the skin is very realistic
and even the hair and the eyes and
everything have really taken the human
character to the new level
when you thought about making a film or
making a story i think those
limits that used to be
you can actually put those away
the fact that a small group of people
can create stunning worlds that are
believable and characters that have so
much emotion
and be able to tell compelling stories
there's nothing like unreal engine 5.
it's an artist's dream
thanks aaron we are blown away by your
work and the sky is the limit moving
forward we are thrilled to be working
with so many incredible partners who are
using unreligion 5 to move the state of
the art forward
in fact we have one more friend to
introduce
thanks dana
crystal dynamics is proud to be a part
of the launch of unreal engine 5.
this new engine translates into next
level storytelling and gameplay
experiences
and that's why we are thrilled to
announce today that we have just started
development of our next tomb raider game
powered by unreal engine 5.
our goal is to push the envelope of
fidelity and to deliver the high quality
cinematic action adventure experience
that fans deserve from both crystal
dynamics and the tomb raider franchise
we can't wait to take this journey
together
thank you and congratulations again to
the epic games team
wow thanks dallas we can't wait to see
what the next chapter of tomb raider
holds so with the end of this very
exciting hour let's recap unreal engine
5 is out and available today in addition
to the lyra starter game an awesome
project you can use to build and ship
your first ue5 game not to mention
thousands of free assets from the matrix
awakens buildings meta humans vehicles
everything you need to get going
building dynamic open worlds
all of this is free to download and use
and be sure to check out the brand new
community hub for even more resources
and to help you get going and connect
with other developers
let's build the future together
[Music]
you